foreign
in Lexington Kentucky in the KY what's
up Ben
uh not much Dr John how you doing and
we're rocking and rolling man y'all
doing well awesome
all right well it's a little cold here
it is cold it is cold so what's up dude
how can I help man
uh well
um me and my wife we've been together
for 13 years okay I've been married for
almost a year and she's always had this
idea that I've been cheating on her and
it's getting to the point where I just I
just can't handle it anymore because
uh you know I'm not cheating on her and
no matter what I tell her
it's always she's got an answer for it
so my question is what can I possibly do
to
keep her from thinking I'm cheating
that's tough man
it's like you're trying to love somebody
and she keeps like putting a wedge
between you right
yeah or coming up with reasons why you
can't get close so
you kind of have a unique relationship
y'all were together 12 years and then
you've been married for one what what
took so long almost one year
um well
you know financial situation you know I
wanted to make sure that I was in a real
stable place before
we got married and you know her as well
um took a decade
yeah yeah I know it's crazy but hey man
teach their own teach their own but here
you are right that's right how long has
she accused you of cheating on her
for the entirety of our relationship I
mean it's I mean it comes and goes it's
it's not an everyday thing but whenever
it is a thing she just never lets it go
so what are the things she points out
that would suggest you're cheating
uh she says I'm always on my phone okay
and are you and no okay I'm I'm really
not I I have no social media
um and if I am on my phone it's it's
either taking phone calls or or just
looking at just like tractor equipment
you know it's just something you know
something nothing you know and I don't
think she realizes a person who's on
their phone all the time because it's
not me gotcha
um
so I don't have any like empirical data
to back this up I'm just going to tell
you something I've seen over and over
and over and over and over again for the
last 20 plus years okay yeah
the things that we are often capable of
or that we've often been guilty of or
that we often think about doing are the
things we often project onto other
people
okay and so my question to you would be
out of the gate has she ever cheated on
you
not that I'm aware of
would it stun you or would it melt you
oh absolutely okay so it wouldn't be
something if you're like yeah I could
see that it would be out of the blue
yeah has somebody ever cheated on her in
a previous relationship that was that
was like a nuclear bomb inside of her
well you know
they're here for so long I mean I heard
her relationships before me were pretty
she hasn't spoke on it so I I can't
really
I don't know
um but you know if I had to point to
something that's her parents are
divorced
um I don't know
if there was infidelity in their
relationship to cause that
um
there's always conflicting stories
between them sure but uh you know that's
not the only thing I could possibly
think of well and it may be that she
picked up that relationships look like
one person accusing the other person all
of the time yeah and that may have been
which the the norm that she grew up with
and in a weird way in a way of trying to
circumvent and prevent or as brene Brown
says dress for her's tragedy like she
spends a lot of time thinking about what
happens what happens what happens what
happens and then she has to ask you and
then it kind of bubbles up and she
explodes on you and you're like what are
you talking about and then it kind of it
it simmers a little bit and it starts
building back up again and up again
you end up creating the very thing that
your body's trying to protect you from
and that's how you get family
dysfunction that happens year after year
generation after generation is in a way
of trying to prevent you from cheating
and driving her crazy what's gonna
happen is are you leaving is somebody
you're gonna run into is gonna be super
chill
and they're gonna laugh at your jokes a
little bit they're going to reach over
and grab something from you and kind of
brush your arm and you're gonna like it
and it's oh that's how these things in
Seoul is gonna just slowly tilt the
other way right has that happened to you
I mean
there's been moments where just women
have spoke to me and how dare you been
just kidding I know it's crazy
I understand all right so let's do this
um
there is not a single thing you can do
the the if I was going to put some blame
somewhere I would start with you and
blame's kind of dramatic I hate using
that word but
um you knew this going in
right if you called and were like dude
out of nowhere she's just insane about
me cheating that would be one thing you
knew this and so part of me says I mean
you you made the bed and you're just
lying in it now you're upset that it's
uncomfortable so there is that okay uh
and if any con if you're gonna have a
conversation with her a direct
conversation I would start there I have
to own my my part in this this has been
going on for a long long time
um and maybe now that y'all are living
together 24 7 365 it's Amplified or
whatever
um let me ask you that question why now
why are you just done now
well we'll see
as probably should have mentioned this
before too she is pregnant and I don't
know if it's her hormones getting all
crazy or what have you but she just
recently whenever I uh emailed you my
question she blew up on me just because
I showed up at the house
without my phone
I mean I just completely forgot it at
the farm
um you know I just it was a total
accident and
she just blew up and I'm like she
wouldn't listen to anything I said and
it just it just really frustrated me
yeah and you know because I wasn't
feeling good that day and she knew that
and I was just stopping by just to get
some aspirin and and instead of you know
asking how I was and you know are you
okay she just automatically said you
know I think you're cheating on me why
don't you have your phone on you um and
all this so it you know it was just a
bad situation so what's your what's your
or what moment
ah
I don't really know John would you leave
her in this new baby no absolutely not
okay
so you're caught between
a value I'm not going anywhere
and I can't keep living like this
right
and I think she knows that
okay so here's a couple of ways a couple
things I would I would tell you first is
um I'm sure you've done this but I it's
it's worth doing it again
probably writing her a letter and I want
you to and here's why writing a letter
is important because I want you to read
her this letter and then I want you to
give it to her
and there's some research about
um the importance of writing things down
that you might stumble over verbally but
when you write it down and you have time
to you know hit the backspace and you
spend the time getting it out it's a lot
more articulate and you get everything
out you get more out than when you try
to talk your body gets nervous kind of
sees up a little bit and there's been
some studies with social media that
suggests like when I was a kid you know
if the school bully on the bus like
talked trash to me and said something
really rude it hurt but there's some
natural mechanisms inside our bodies
that help us that
um it kind of dissipates over time
especially if that person is not like my
parents or somebody in my closed Circle
when it comes to social media it's black
and white and it's posted and so you can
read it over and over and over and over
again that same thing I'm going with the
idea that it also works in reverse and
I've seen this over and over where if
you tell her I'm not cheating on you she
is already accused you she's in fight or
flight game is on she's not hearing any
new data she's just in a fight now but
when she's calm and she goes back to
this letter and then she's calm later on
goes back to this letter and she's at
peace and goes back to this letter
it's going to reinforce and reinforce
and reinforce okay so I'd recommend
writing this stuff down and then taking
her out somewhere and reading it to her
okay
um it will probably be hard to read but
it's important that you have a clear
path ahead for her
I would note that this is
um on you not on her okay the moment you
said and then you do this then she's off
right she's got to defend herself
the statements that I would make are
I work really really hard to love you
the best I can
and I'm beginning to feel
um like I can't breathe
cause every moment I walk in this house
I'm being accused of being a liar and a
cheater two things that I don't put up
with in my life I don't put up with my
friends
and I'm struggling to continue to
um be connected in this relationship
because it's a constant attack
and
I think the next statement I would go
with and again this is just me
I'm choosing to be well I want to be a
good dad I want to be a good husband and
I can't continue to do it in this
context so when you choose to accuse me
of something that I have not done will
never do
I'm going to choose you're choosing to
send me away and I'm going to choose to
go for a walk to take a little kid out
to head back to the farm I'm going to
choose to not be in this situation I'm
not going to leave you but I'm gonna
choose to be well as well as I possibly
can how does that sound
it sounds good but you know I just I
just know her and I don't know I just
don't know if she'll I feel like I've
done all those things just not in a
letter form and it's it's like it goes
in one ear and out the other honestly I
I don't know how she would handle that I
I know and I I would tell you it's time
to take a stand
and I tried and and you know but here's
the problem with taking the stand is
you're not going to leave you're not
going anywhere
yeah and but
I guess it's you know that's that's the
thing is she knows that I'm not going to
leave and it's almost like I have to
leave and then just see what what how
she changes
right or if she does or if you leaving
validates all of her fears that she's
been coming have you have you talked to
her about going to marriage counseling
I don't know if I want to go to marriage
counseling you know I just well that's
done why wouldn't you want to go
well I just I like to work things out
myself you know I know I'm calling you
it's not working yeah it's 13 years it's
not working
I know I know I like to fix my car by
myself too and that usually doesn't work
and I have to take it into someone
yeah is that fair
yeah that's yeah I mean you're right
here's the deal
um I've said this before and get a
little bit of smoke from it and I don't
care I look at Fidelity in a marriage
relationship in a romantic relationship
much bigger
then
somebody putting a body part inside of
somebody else
so like I know it's easy to say like
Fidelity I've never cheated on anybody
I've never had sex with somebody else
I think Fidelity and cheating and
um being whole in a marriage is way
bigger than sex
I think that somebody who walks in and
steals your dignity every day calls you
a liar to your face repeatedly over and
over and over again
someone who you've probably shown all of
your phone or all of your text and all
of your deleted stuff and you've
probably they've probably tracked you
around with the little app and all that
stuff oh yeah so what you're what you
have to realize you're not dealing with
data here you're not dealing with
there's not a thing you can do there's
not like a data point that she's gonna
go ah okay phew that's not gonna happen
and I think there's a bigger issue here
when it comes to cheating or it comes to
Fidelity in a relationship she is making
choices to separate the two of you
or she's making choices to not be in
relationship with you
and she's choosing to do that not by
having sex with somebody else that you
know of but she's choosing to put wedges
between the two of you so that you
cannot get close
and then she's blaming you for that
distance
see what I'm saying yeah I get it yeah
this is a bigger deal than I think you
are allowing yourself to believe it to
be
well I know it's a big deal
um but I just I don't know I just I just
wish it would stop
dude you know that's the greatest line
of this Show's history I know it's a big
deal I just wish it would stop that's
exactly right that's exactly exactly
exactly right 100 percent
you're you're a good man who works on
the farm and when a problem like
presents itself yeah you fix that
problem and you literally take bailing
wire and uh some hay and you solve that
problem and maybe some duct tape and you
can't do that on this one
because somebody on the other field just
keeps throwing cocktail Molotov
cocktails on your field and setting it
on fire and at some point you can't just
keep going out there and putting out the
fire you have to stop and say enough is
enough is enough
and quite frankly I think the step
forward is marriage counseling because
something is going on inside of your
wife
that is making her that is that is
pushing her that is encouraging her to
choose to
make the guy that loves her more than
anybody on planet Earth the bad guy
constant bad guy an inability to be at
peace in relationship she is choosing an
anxious life
and there's not a thing you can do about
it at this point other than to begin to
create a world where you have to protect
yourself and the world that this little
baby is going to come into
I would be on the first train into a
marriage counselor because this this
relationship has a little has very short
legs on it if you don't get involved
very very quickly and get a third party
in there
you've tried your best my man you've
tried and you just want to go away you
try to solve it and it's not
so now you can do one of two things
except what is
and live a life of quiet desperation
hang your head low like millions and
millions and millions of men have done
or you can look at her and say you're
worth fighting for we are worth fighting
for this family's worth fighting for and
I'm not giving up I'm calling a marriage
counselor we got to go do this because
we need help right now thanks for the
call Ben